God I hope I'm streaming to the right
place hi my name is Markiplier I
survived I did it I made it through
I saw the other side but not not in that
way I didn't go towards the light if you
know what I mean
I saw everything that I needed to saw
and then I didn't see what I didn't need
to see and I'm here now in front of you
and you are seeing me
at the other side
I didn't
I'm through
I succeeded
I survived
no
am I streaming
yes probably it's been so long since
I've done this YouTube thing I've
forgotten how to do it at all
um but yeah I survived I had covid I
somehow made it this entire time without
catching it and recently I went to
Korean on the way back boy howdy did I
catch it and boy howdy does it suck so
uh don't recommend it
yeah somehow I got yeah I'm alive I'm
alive if you didn't see my community
post a few like a week and a few days
back I got covered like I got coveted
and it was just man I could tell you the
details but there's other things uh that
occurred in that time frame that you
guys don't know anything about that is
actually kind of uh significant
so I'm gonna start it off by saying
chica is just fine
there's nothing I mean chica is fine
this is part of the whole Smorgasbord of
things that happened I will get to them
one at a time there's many things in a
row in addition that has occurred over
the past couple weeks that I need to get
to soon enough but I'm really getting
ahead of the curve here and saying that
chica is 100 okay
so I like that's that's the best part of
it and then secondary to that is I'm
okay now I feel better I feel 100 and I
feel ready to tackle the world again
I've got a crazed look in my eye and I'm
just oh I'm just eager oh I'm eager but
yes chica is fine I will go into uh the
details of why chica is fine and the
points at which she may not have been
fine uh in a moment it is okay no one
panic I know you're already panicking
but it is okay
so
I was in Korea just a couple weeks ago
it was very fun saw my family if you
didn't know I'm Korean some people seem
to not know that I'm half Korean on my
mom's side if you haven't seen videos
with me and my mom she's funnier than I
am and she also wrote a book and she
also uh let me make a documentary about
the story in the book and so we were in
Korea filming the remainder of that
story
um yes chica is doing good uh and then
basically that went perfectly fine it
went very well it was actually a
coincidence because
literally we went around chuseok which
is Korean Thanksgiving it's a very dense
time we're actually in the car being
driven around by my cousin hyungbe uh
way more than we were actually exploring
Korea but it's fine because we filmed
everything that we needed to do for my
mom's documentary uh that will be coming
out in the next couple months if you
don't show up for the premiere of my
mom's documentary my mother will disown
me and you
so don't let that happen I haven't
announced a date of when it in but keep
it in the back of your mind like a fear
like a monster in your closet or under
your bed it could be coming at any
moment and if you miss it remember my
mom will be sad
and then I will be in your basement
ready and lurking in the darkness to
chase you up the stairs when you try to
flip the light off
so you better show up to the premiere of
it because it's my mom's story and it's
about Korea and if you care anything
about me my mom or Korea
then you will come watch the premiere of
the documentary titled Markiplier from
North Korea that is the actual title of
it no I will not explain it more later
or now so thank you
yes you don't have a basement that's
what you think
that's what you think
am I lying
or are you lying to yourself
okay but while we were in
Korea uh like obviously we couldn't
bring Chica and Henry with us uh we got
a call that said uh chica unfortunately
suffered from heat stroke uh now that
sounds really scary I know and it was
but like I said at the beginning of this
I wanted to reiterate I'm not holding
this over your heads to be like oh your
watch to the end or I'm in a bit no
chica is fine 100 A-Okay but you can
imagine our fear while we are in a
completely different country and hear
such news
um if you didn't know that uh in La
there's been a lot of heat waves but
it's not like the person who was
watching over uh chica didn't have air
conditioning uh it just so happened that
um she had a small infection that we
didn't know about before we left for
Korea or that she picked up afterwards
uh it's unclear when or where but again
reiterating she is completely 100 fine
now
um but it was a Show's chica for proof
uh I gotta go get her
do you not believe me that she is fine
she is one she is 100
A-Okay she is 100 just just I got I have
to uh listen the screen's gonna go real
bright okay it's gonna go real bright I
just just trust me on this it's gonna be
fine everything's gonna be fine
everything hold still hold still don't
move don't move don't move don't move
don't move don't move don't move it's
okay it's okay it's okay it's okay it's
okay it's great everything's fine
everything's fine
everything's fine everything's fine hold
it hold it right there
do
all right guys good good good good hold
hold that hold that hold that hold hold
hold that hold that okay everything's
fine everything's fine do you see a
light do you see a light do you see my
hands Don't Panic don't scream do not
scream whatever you do do not blink do
not blink in this moment it is very
crucial I'm not saying you'll lose your
vision forever if you blink at this
moment don't blink don't blink don't
blink and good
you blinked
you're lucky it was after it was done
chica come here
and there's Henry too if you wanted to
see Henry let me scoot it down a little
bit a little bit so they're fine yes 100
A-Okay okay I I for some reason my
tripod's not cooperating but you get a
slanted tilt this is a cool angle
there's a cool angle but there's Jake
it's totally fine Chico are you fine are
you okay did you get a little bit of a
heat stroke now heat stroke sounds
really bad that's because it is but
chica as you can see he's 100 fine Henry
it's okay
maybe it's okay too you're fine Henry
did not suffer heat stroke so Henry is
a-okay man I should do all of my let's
play [ __ ] this is a cool angle and then
I could have chica come in every
she's a very cutie uh
chica is a paid actor now chica is an
unpaid actor uh chica don't bring this
up uh around chica because then she will
realize how much she is actually owed
for uh the amount of content she's been
in without being
okay okay anyway so chica uh prove
you're okay
she's nuzzling into my hand
snuggling into my hand she's nuzzling in
to my hand and there's Henry hi good boy
Henry come here hey hop up pop up up up
it's slippery in here she can't hop up
she's all right trust me she's all right
she's she still has legs
yeah
yeah
all right anyway I gotta I gotta hold on
just uh just I don't don't blink diet
whatever you do don't blink
all right chica all right thank you very
much thank you very much goodbye
yeah
all right it's coming back in three two
one you're a pro you're a champ you're
good at this all right I'm gonna keep
this angle is pretty cool but anyway so
uh I also am fine
I survived I'm alive which is very cool
you know I had covid and now I feel much
better except I've got like this
lingering bit of phlegm that I have to
cough up uh
should not lose her legs she could
definitely still has her legs I don't
know what you guys are talking about
I don't know you guys are talking about
you could definitely 100 still has it
her legs
anyway uh so yeah I have spent the last
few days covet this sucked so much like
I'm vaccinated obviously and boosted
um and even with those it sucked I my
throat burned more than any other time
I've been sick in my entire life
literally I woke up in the middle of the
night so many times just like I it's
breathing fire breathing fire uh coughs
not so much snot but I am okay I have
survived yeah so I'm alive where are
chica's legs
trick question
on chica
so yeah it definitely sucked uh be aware
it's still out there you know
um and it's just something to be
uh aware of definitely go get your
vaccines because man without it it would
have been freaking awful I can't even
imagine uh so I'm back though which is
fantastic because that means I can get
back into the swing of actually making
content I am for the foreseeable future
not for an extended period of time going
out of town and filming anything or
doing any big project for a little bit
um and it's good because I think that
well I mean obviously I always fill my
time with stuff to do because I always
have things that I like to do and I
always keep busy but at the same time oh
yeah Amy got it too but Amy Amy's doing
all right as well we're all doing fine
everyone's good we all are here we're
all fine
uh such a such a dynamic angle uh anyway
so there was something else that I was
supposed to say something extremely
important
um that I've completely forgotten about
is Twitch exploding I'm so far removed
from everything on the internet that I
have no idea what is going on at all
um and here I am live streaming on
YouTube you know occasionally live
stream on Twitch but I've I heard
Rumblings that like twitch was
absolutely exploding and I had I have no
idea it is it is
that's what people said like they
changed the revenue split or something
to something 50 50.
um it's cutting pay okay that that makes
sense when it's owned by a a trillion
dollar company it's fine lowering
payments from 70 30 to 50 50.
for everything
Mark you're exploding I'm I don't think
I'm exploding I'm pretty sure I am
intact
which is exploding your dad owns twitch
wow your dad is Mr Amazon that's
incredible uh I I think twitch might
still be there 100 sure about that
actually
um twitch band gambling that's good
that's always good
happy for that the revenue thing is
interesting though because if it's is it
50 50 ad rates or is it 50 50
also subscription fees
because I get I've thought for a long
time that maybe twitch had been not
doing the best but at the same time oh
yeah my hair's hair is getting longer I
haven't got it for a long time and I
actually got a haircut to this length so
that it sits a little better and isn't a
complete like straight out everywhere
um there was gambling on Twitch oh yeah
it was gambling 50 50 overall
really
50 50 Subs that's important because I
was about to say like if it's 50 50 ad
Revenue then I can't really say that
YouTube's any better than that because I
think the the YouTube ad Revenue split
is 55.45
I'm pretty sure I haven't checked in a
very long time I don't usually check
those things
but if it's ad if it's subscription to
that's that's really rough
oh yeah and Wade took over for go my
favorite sports team yes and I'm really
appreciated for that if you haven't
listened to go my favorite sports team
definitely go check that out that's a
podcast with me and Tyler where he
teaches me about sports because I don't
know anything about sports there's also
a video on the gmfst uh YouTube channel
where he teaches me how to throw a
perfect spiral and there will be more
videos where we go on rambunctious
adventures together for All Time and
Eternity
um but at the same time Wade Wade popped
off
is that good is that does that mean good
the Wade did Wade whip his dick out on
the podcast
did he
did he did he pull his [ __ ] out
did he do that I
let's just say that he did I'm gonna
assume that Wade dropped trial and uh
swung his dick around like a helicopter
right on the GM FST podcast and you can
hear that live occurring when you listen
to the GM FST podcast
on Spotify or apple podcast or wherever
it is there's a link in the description
actually where you can check out the
whirring sound as is Dick whips past the
microphone it's true 100 true we will
all swear to the authenticity of this
statement and no one will disavow it
right correct cool and everyone say that
it was very cool and sounded great so
and then they all applauded yeah exactly
uh but so Wade popped off on that and I
am grateful for him stepping it because
I literally couldn't talk for a while
there it was it hurt to talk it's still
like I'm 95 of the way there like if I
take a kova test right now it's like the
tiniest like like tiniest little sliver
but technically it's still there so
technically I still have it
um but I feel almost 100 just hacking up
some stuff in a few a few snot Rockets
here and there
um but all in all thank you everybody
for your patience I know videos have not
been regular and while I don't apologize
for resting up when I am sick I do
apologize because I literally had videos
that I could have posted but I felt so
bad and just wanted to lay in bed uh
that I literally didn't post them they
are sitting on my hard drive right now
the hard work of my uh like illustrious
editors as being wasted I literally have
and so many of you have been asking for
another like Amazon review video which I
did I did I have it it is literally
uploaded on my channel fidget toy review
I review a bunch of ADHD toys I finally
talk about my ADHD not in a good way not
saying in a bad way but just in a very
inelegant way you know the way I talk
about things that's what is this I'm
looking at it right now I could hit
public on this and it would go up but I
don't have a thumbnail right and if I
don't have a thumbnail I can't post a
video no matter what it just don't work
for me I can't do that but but and I
know it would take me 30 minutes to get
the thumbnail done the description but
even today I just haven't done it yet
I've been looking at it all day I'm like
I should get that up I should definitely
do that and then I don't which is
fascinating because you would love this
video it's so funny like it's just
really really funny like the editing's
great oh it's good I've got part two of
it steals nightmare of Decay growing my
grandpa and this other game called close
your eyes I've got them all I've got
five videos just sitting on my hard
drive that I could upload and give to
you and I haven't
I have no excuse for that you should be
enraged at me at this moment I pretty
much try to maintain a standard level of
Rage from you guys towards me because I
feel like if you have rage towards me
you kind of uh forget about all the
other troubles in your life I try to be
like a lightning rod of hate but in this
case it is not my intentional antagonism
it is just the fact that I have been
lazy because I am feeling better now as
you can see I'm not suffering any
symptoms
and yet I'm staring at the video that I
have not posted and I don't think I'll
post it for the rest of the night
because it's too late I don't wanna I
don't wanna send notifications out there
to people who are already gone to bed I
would say it's a 440 where I am you
can't post a video at this point I post
a video
I post videos at midnight all the time
um
usually the extremely scary ones I'm not
lying this video is freaking great oh so
my name is
it's so funny it's 45 minutes of me
going through like 30 different toys
it's great I ramble you know like I'm
rambling now you guys watch the reviews
videos for MREs and
Sour Patch Kids
Takis
you love them you love those things I've
got one sitting right here literally
right I could show it to you I could
show you I'm I'm not bullshitting either
I have it I have it right here like uh
I'll I'll show you I'll show you I'll
show you let me close all my porn tabs
real quick let me turn off that
thank you
yeah I'll turn I'll turn off the porn
hang on one second I gotta
okay one second one second here you guys
will see I ain't I ain't lying why would
I lie see
there it is it's a whole new video hold
look 40 uh you can't see but it's 46
minutes long look at this look at this
video you would love this video if it
was up on my channel you would love this
it's great look at this look at that I
bet you you don't even know what that is
but it's funny uh I think maybe I hope
God if this this video is like a
disappointment I'm gonna be really upset
anyway uh this is not gonna make a lot
of sense to you none of this will but
you know it is what it is
it is what it is but man if only you
could watch this video right now and the
only thing stopping me is literally
hitting the publish button
this is the problem this is me wrestling
with myself if you can't tell this video
where I review
ADHD uh toys
um I have ADHD I'm not doing this
because I mean I'm doing this because
I've been so distracted by other hyper
fixations that I have not been able to
tear myself away from them uh to be able
to do the necessary steps to be able to
get that up
yep
what are you talking about I haven't
even looked over in chat forever I I
always just go on these tangents and I
just assume you were you were in a
certain mood and my God you were I
haven't done a thumbnail for it I
haven't done it that is the thing that
is stopping me right now the description
and the title are not that complicated
it's just like I do a thumbnail and it's
not even like I do the intense one with
that I I do the cliche hard bright
outline arrows oh I have ADHD anyway
it's it's not the point I'm not gonna I
I'm talking to you guys I'm catching up
I'm telling you about my life about my
passions about my passions about my pet
you think making videos is my passion it
is but making content is my passion the
latest hyper fixation that I have inside
my soul uh leave a like if you want to
hear my latest hyper fixation if you
want to be bored into tears with my
latest Endeavor Into The Madness of the
internet then hit that like button ring
that Bell subscribe today if you want to
hit that uh and watch my
ADHD fidget toy video when it comes out
in the future you'll have to check it
out ring that Bell to know when it's
going up could be any time no idea I
don't have
I don't have a thumbnail I don't have
one are you gonna make a thumbnail for
me are you gonna take a screenshot of
those a few little segments of the video
that I just revealed and then go make a
thumbnail that's exactly like the other
thumbnails that I make in that review
series I'm not a professional at what I
do in any way I'm a hobbyist that is
somehow slipped his way into the upper
echelons of YouTube I don't know how it
happened you enabled me to be here I
accidentally
stumbled my way
to this many subscribers that I have you
think that there was any kind of
intention to it do you think that there
was any design to what I do do you think
there's any like criteria any like
metadata analysis there's none
I literally just kind of [ __ ] things out
and it's worked out for 10 years
straight
that's it I have no plan that's my big
secret to YouTube I have no plan ever
always and that's my plan to never have
a plan
do you get it you understand me do you
give a little insight into my mind
anyway my hyper fixation have you guys
heard of Novel AI
I've been like talking a little bit
about the various AI things and I always
say AI with quotes
um novel AI is a different version it's
like talk to Transformer which I think
is called something else now I forget
what it is I did a video on it I can't
remember what it is it's like it comes
up with stories right
however
the newest update of Novel Ai and I'm
not sponsored by them I just have
thoroughly been enjoying it the newest
version of Novel AI is quite good it is
surprisingly good whereas doctor
Transformer it was cute it was funny it
would come up with the most ridiculous
[ __ ] things all the time talk to
Transformer
it's kind of scary how much it helps in
terms of just like spitballing ideas and
I know it's a slippery slope because
like oh who's writing you or the AI and
I don't use it as like a supplement to
write things for me what it's great at
is coming up with a constant stream of
ideas I've talked about like writing
before and writing might be boring to
some of you guys but I don't care what
you guys think I'm gonna talk about it
anyway so I've been writing a lot more
and I've been getting into writing and I
used to hate writing and now I love
writing
um and what my biggest advice in writing
with people were like how do you write
and I was like I don't [ __ ] know I
stumbled into writing I don't know I
don't know how I got here you know every
day I wake up I'm like I don't know
where I am three weeks from now I'm
gonna wonder why my camera is tilted
I guarantee you three weeks from now I
will look at my camera and be like why
is it tilted because I will have
stumbled to this moment
where I tilted it in the screen in this
stream
and I will leave it that way because I
will forget
what was I talking about
I literally I forgot what I was thinking
about
what are they talking about bro stumbled
into everything I have I have I'm a very
lucky guy just so happened to stumble
into the right spots writing right so my
biggest advice in terms of writing is to
just write no matter what I often talk
about this app called danger notes
danger notes is a great writing tool
because if you stop writing
if you you need to write for five
minutes straight and if you stop writing
at any point in there well
just like that if you stop writing for
any point in there uh it'll delete
everything
did my channel get deleted
no it's fine yes everything's good I'm
still streaming
I think anyway it wouldn't matter if I
was I don't even know I don't even know
if anyone's listening to this I kind of
just ramble into the void but if you
stop writing for any moment there it
will delete what you wrote unless you
can make it to five minutes of constant
writing and then you're allowed to save
it or at least you can copy and paste it
into something else or you could delete
it or whatever the most important thing
is just to continue writing doesn't
matter what you write just get to the
next idea and that has saved my ass so
many times once I learned that trick of
just literally keep writing never stop
writing and if you stop writing you're
doing something horribly wrong right so
that's kind of what novel AI has done
for me in a different aspect what it
does is I write and then I hit come up
with something and it'll usually be not
quite right but occasionally it'll be on
the right track and I'll be like
that's not bad let me modify this let me
tweak this is more what I was thinking
of I just guide it back on track and I
suddenly discovered that over the past
four days I've written about
50 000 words in the past four days
twenty five thousand of which I have
written with my own fingers and that's
pretty good that's not bad that's five
thousand a day that's or a little more
than five thousand dig it's like six and
a half thousand a day that was pretty
good day of writing I'd say
they doubled my writing it about doubled
my writing and I was like
that was pretty good gosh not bad it
turned my really good day of writing to
an incredible day of writing where I got
over 10 000 words on a page of good
stuff that I wanted
that was pretty cool I like that I think
there's a scary future where the AI
programs will be writing things
four people and then the the soul of
creation will escape from Humanity's
hearts forever and I will have to I
don't know jerk off in a corner forever
oh woe is me the computers took my germ
you know stuff stuff like that I'll
stumble into something else just like I
do everything else but
it's pretty cool it it is pretty cool
for now in this in this space of time
where we exist where the AI are
developing and they're able to make
images that are pretty cool and stuff
like that it's fun right now in this
moment 10 years from now well I guess I
won't need to make videos anymore
because the programs can make videos
with my face with my voice just as good
as I could make but actually even better
than I can make because they've
watched my entire backlog of videos and
they were able to copy my style and they
have my DNA because I spent so long
jerking off in the corner over there but
uh yeah so the Clones of me will take
over the world in the near future just
like the movie Oblivion but for now it's
a cool space and I do like novel AI I
hate having another subscription service
I hate paying another
certain dollars a month but hey
this is kind of fun
it's not bad you know I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna lie it's not big
not big
anyway so you guys got any questions for
me uh chica is 100 fine like I said
chica 100 fine everything's good I'm 100
fine Amy is 100 fine everything is 100
fine I have many Grand Ambitions for
things that I want to do uh my mom's
documentary is going to be coming out in
the next couple months and if you don't
watch it
monsters will suck on your toes and not
in a good way if you're into that yeah
what's happening will the documentary be
free no because my mom wants a Payday
you're gonna give it to her
anyway
uh no game suggestions these aren't good
questions these are never good questions
nav cloak drop yeah there's a FNAF cloak
drop it's coming
I should know when that's happening I I
should know I should know that
what's my favorite genre of Reading
Writing I I read a lot of Warhammer 40K
that's pretty much all I do writing I'll
write whatever comes to mind
I have no idea
uh what music is playing right now I
don't even know music was playing
it's music playing hey is there music I
don't have my headphones on here's the
music
that's nice I forgot I turned on Lo-Fi
I do that like literally on Instinct uh
have I seen Lick scene's game no I saw
some kind of a notification that he did
make a game I gotta check that out I've
not been in communication for about a
week because I don't think
Mommy good
hey Sexton career you enjoyed visiting
uh we saw many things not much in terms
of new stuff but it was you'll see in
the you'll see there live in La Vida
Loca yeah we went to the we went to
noribang the karaoke which is very fun
very very fun oh also follow my cousin
young Bay on Instagram he is uh going to
be a big famous actor in Korea and I
love him very much with all my heart and
if you don't help make him a big famous
actor in Korea he has a Netflix movie
out oh I gotta check out what the name
of that the movie it's not his movie but
he's in the movie you know he's in the
movie on Netflix so I gotta find that
out either way go follow him on
Instagram I follow him I made a couple
posts with him tagged in there
um he's he's a great great guy
wonderful
32 000 people watching and only twenty
six thousand likes likes
likes her
fart in the Wind
you know I don't really matter it'll
trickle out there don't worry too much
about likes don't worry too much about
numbers
just stumble your way through life with
uh
it's controlled stumbling is what I do I
do controlled stumbling I'm stumbling
but with style that's how I'd say I
stumble
also I watched that Tick Tock about talk
about talking in your true voice and it
affected me and I I started to question
whether I was actually talking in my
true voice
[Music]
hello everybody I am right okay I'll
work on that so thank you am I still
living la vida loca I never stopped
none of us ever did
so I'm going thank you every so and so
much I will get that video up tomorrow
along with more regular videos I said to
myself that I would get it up today
well anyway thank you chica is good
chica has all her legs I am good look
forward to more content coming very soon
you guys love that content don't you
you love that content
you need it and I'll provide if if
content is what you want I can provide
so that I will very soon good stuff good
delicious
content
content I meant to buy some clothes in
Korea
I didn't
time
anyway I'll go back soon thank you have
a good day have a wonderful day drink
your milk